atlanta's
been wild during the pandemic because
there's been i was there in uh
january and i was like this [ __ ] is wild
like this [ __ ] was why the [ __ ] opened
it
out there nick trigg how was that yeah
it was
uh it was i mean because i live in l.a
so it's been like
the other extreme yeah it's worse it was
worse i had all right
well no just like i mean i guess but
just the restrictions like
i feel like we can do [ __ ] out here you
couldn't go to a restaurant atlanta with
oakland
now we went to atlanta i was like yo
where i'm over here eating hot wings and
looking at
[ __ ] right now the strip clubs was
the first thing
oh like they i feel like the strip clubs
closed for like a month and then they
was like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
yeah and the food man i'll tell you what
was overrated those magic city's hot
wings i was very disappointed
what blue flame much better okay cool i
could fight with that
and then there was this white strip club
that played like nickelback that
everyone told me to go to he went to the
white way was the pink pony
yes no you can't go no no no no i went
to the pink pony with jaren benton
and he took us to this other place where
there was like [ __ ] strippers and old
ladies
claremont lounge i ain't never heard of
that you guys know about that you know
that is
no but there's another club that's like
no everyone goes to to eat food
that's that's magic of blue flame like
no no
no no no no every rapper was like you
got to go here don't worry about the
music or the women but the food is
fire i don't know what it look like i
don't know i'm trying to remember the
name of this place but i went to the
pink pony the pink pony was whatever
yeah that's some like it's like a grand
theft auto type strip club
yeah i went to like 12 of them i was
like the whole time
that's good we're just at the strip club
all right where we going tonight you got
to go to the
real ratchet five dollars oh i went to
all of that but listen we was it we we
we went to all of them i just told i
told killer mike i said where do i need
to go
okay you that's that's cool go here go
here
and then and he didn't say go to magic
city but i was like i gotta go
and then the wings were so tiny you went
to blue flame or magic first
uh i went to magic city first standing
with the blue flame blue flame was much
better
yeah that's a the food this is your
preference though you like ratchet [ __ ]
but i feel like magic city is like i'm
just in my
cuisine um just the food